Haley Bieber shares her latest Health
Challenge I'm very grateful and thankful
on Monday the model shared this snap to
her insta story Haley lifting up her
sweatshirt to expose her bare stomach
alongside it Haley who's married to
Justin Bieber noted that the Small Bump
is not a baby instead she explained its
assist on her ovary the size of an apple
Haley wrote she doesn't have
endometriosis or polycystic ovary
syndrome but she has had ovarian cysts
in the past quote it's painful and achy
and makes me feel nauseous and Bloated
and crampy and emotional anyways I'm
sure a lot of you can overly relate and
understand we got this
but this isn't the first time Haley's
been candid about her health I felt this
really weird Sensation that kind of like
traveled down my arm from my shoulder
all the way down to my fingertips back
in March she revealed she was
hospitalized After experiencing
stroke-like symptoms
like are you okay when I went to respond
I couldn't speak the right side of my
face started drooping definitely the
scariest moment of my life I had so many
things running through my head
the number one thing being I'm having a
stroke Haley explained that she suffered
a very small blood clot in her brain but
her body passed it on its own and Haley
later had a procedure done to close the
hole in her heart where the clot escaped
it went very smoothly I'm recovering
really well really fast I feel great and
while Haley might be battling a new
Health Challenge now she's keeping it
positive and has lots to celebrate
she recently rang in her 26th birthday
in Tokyo with her hubby and BFFs Kendall
Jenner and Justine Skye
and the entrepreneur Graces the cover of
Forbes latest issue joining the mags
under 30 class of 2023 thanks to the
success of her skincare line road I
think my favorite part of this whole
entire process is
the creative process and that I get to
be in charge of the creative process a
lot of the time you know I've lent my
name and my face to other people's
creative process and I think that
actually has helped me develop mine in a
lot of ways but it feels very empowering
to to be the one that is in charge
whether she's running her own business
or keeping it real with her fans on
social media one thing's for sure Haley
is a boss 24 7.
foreign